[Music]
I'm Thomas Sumner I'm the earth and
environmental sciences reporter for
science news magazine about 66 million
years ago there was a devastating
disaster on earth and about
three-quarters of all plant of animal
species got wiped out in a geologic
incident and that's been a mystery for
decades and he might have heard in
school that everything died the
space-rock impact but not everybody
believes that and to help answer that
question a team of researchers has gone
back to the scene of the crime off the
coast of Mexico this giant 200 kilometer
across the crater called Chicxulub but
he dropped three giant cow legs into the
sea jack themself out of the waters laid
a stable platform and then drilled
straight down into what's called the
peak ring as his ring of mountains
within the crater itself so in November
they reported in science that the rocks
in this peak ring or from way down
kilometers down when the impact
originally hit and that means that the
simulations of the impact itself are
right because they predicted that those
deep rocks have returned to the surface
and it's really exciting because means
that the scientists can trust the models
and then they can then use those models
to see how much stuff was kicked up with
the atmosphere how much energy was
released and what might have happened to
the critters of our lives in time so in
February I will be putting out a
in-depth feature story of looking at
this question what killed the dinosaurs
and I will be looking both at the new
research coming out of
impact site with the drilling project as
well as some of the first evidence of
animals directly killed by the impact of
the work basically swallowed whole by
the tsunami that came roaring out from
the impact site and I'll also be looking
at the other faction that has been
researching the end of the dinosaurs and
they do not think it was the impact they
think it was something else and they are
currently rallying around the Deccan
Traps which are these colossal volcanic
eruptions in what is now India that
blanketed the landscape with kilometers
thick layers of lava and it was a really
really big eruption bears claiming that
that eruption built up co2 in the
atmosphere it is sittest by the oceans a
lot of the same things we're doing right
now and kill a whole bunch of stuff and
they're saying that that was the
dominant driver of the end of the
dinosaurs this drilling project and a
lot of other research projects regarding
this horrible extinction event i've
already told us a lot but there are some
big questions of remaining and a lot of
the findings are is making those
collections even bigger so 2017 is going
to be interesting one way or the other
whether or not we really solve the
dinosaurs
you
[Music]